hey how's it going bros my name is
welcome to three free games today we
have as every [ __ ] day some games to
play these games will change your life
they're free you can play them but I'm
gonna play them first baby don't know
why I'm winking to you now I can't stop
now it's a thing the first game is
called tried I repeat here it is this is
the game I can continue I can okay we
are evil labs the biggest corporation on
the planet we do tests to improve the
life of all living beings recently we
received an opportunity to perform so
cute
Sakia oh my god that's fabulous what are
they doing in there
it just keeps going is that us move or
gem J did I do it
welcome to our lab subject number one
you know when there's a [ __ ] casualty
count that I wanna jump no why
trying Jesus Christ sir I am jumping oh
[ __ ] I don't trust the hello Anna for
[ __ ] sake or to [ __ ] for us oh
that's cool ha ha ha ha oh come on
moustache man God yes
no I'm Isis man you suck death
everywhere come on come on there we go
yes
Czech boy you've made it now the real
fun starts what I can kill myself
that's horrible am i wearing panties in
my face never wear panties in your face
come on yeah baby
whoa doing good this is really cool game
this time I like it
look at me dance look at me dance look
at me dance look at me dance yes yeah
can I gotta kill my eyes that don't eh
Ok Go damn it giant head man go yeah um
ok I'm out you big that's what you said
now it's your time - thanks oh I think
yes oh [ __ ] damn it I gotta keep myself
oh look at its a panty face
how does there's panty smell mate yes
yeah awesome
fish game best thing the best game for
rich gamer and use your knife and go and
thank you please shut up shut your
[ __ ] mouth
yeah [ __ ] ok now we have a situation in
here yes
activate the protocol are you in
okay
you
at one small step for man
it's called PewDiePie thank you thank
you what an honor what an honor that a
human being thought yes okay all right
all right all right
whoo-hoo dude that [ __ ] that dare to
invoke me PewDiePie the fabulous your
mom game of the year is that it was that
the game I like I like the song though
oh I can answer here decline a fabulous
how can I help you
give me the power please how do you
smell my ass ha ha wrong answer
got it all right not everyone wants to
smell your eyes julinho check clearly
supposed to be there that was
implemented [ __ ] sake oh god that
[ __ ] thing is gonna oh [ __ ] dick ol
midgut I wonder how sex with dick butt
looks like it must be pretty [ __ ]
kinky am I the only one who has ever
thought of these things come on I bet
you thought of it too as soon as
specialist is he saw my beautiful face
on it dick I this is I want this song to
be played on my funeral no seriously
that I forget about it again I'm
taunting it with my beautiful dick bud
yes yes yes yes this game no dad damn
Mountain Dew
[ __ ] me I hate with that how do I dodge
that I supposed to do I shoot with
controls
Stefano's that guess
oh boy did it no that's [ __ ] yeah
I don't notice but 'king [ __ ] I'm
sweating over dick bun I did it [ __ ]
this game this game doesn't know me
this proves nothing I'm still I'm still
here we are yeah Los Angeles shark [ __ ]
yes let's start this [ __ ] alright so
this game you're playing a shark and
you're supposed to eat as many one oh my
god oh my god they're all dead
hey sound but it exploded what is going
on there's a helicopter get it come here
now your cover with a Logano that's my
[ __ ] you're in my domain that's right
your yard [ __ ] oh yeah explosion more
people keep up yes
I can't keep up get the helicopter yeah
yeah boy Willy
suck my Willy it's just so [ __ ] good
Oh what's my kite another helicopter
yeah come with me how they got there
ah yeah that's rapper you can't escape
me I am done holy [ __ ] I feel like I'm
on steroids or some [ __ ] [ __ ] not
that I would know but Jesus Christ how
long does this keep going Oh marina the
rain
oh my god are you kidding me
alright come with me Oh Oh God not the
hell the [ __ ] airplane okay fine
you're never safe you're not escaping
them haha alright that happened a duck
[ __ ] really what not that duck is it
over oh my god that was amazing salad
King salad cake alright well I got the
high score
there's achievements to unlock that's
[ __ ] awesome Rose you gotta check
this game out I don't think there's much
more to that one game but hey what did
we learn today Bryce that dick butts are
nice I agree I agree I'm glad we got
through that [ __ ] together
alright well I would like to hold hands
with you shake hands I don't know this
is brofist alright okay you ready
what is this what even
hey I don't understand I have so many
important take this [ __ ] that's
right I'm from the hood [ __ ]